business secretaries call crisis talks
with the suppliers tomorrow um
if you were sitting in his seats what
would you be asking them to do
well the short term in the long term in
the short term
what the business secretary must do is
ensure continuity of supply that's a
basic duty of government
for both
domestic consumers and for businesses
and we've seen
other ramifications of this over the
last 24-48 hours for example on food
supplies with co2 being a necessary
byproduct and in the long term what this
has shown
is
the need to get on with the transition
to net zero
and the vulnerability of the reliance on
fossil fuel markets uh especially
international ones so there are things
that you can't change because the
situation is here and now but this
should act as a spur to get on with the
transition to net zero more renewable
and sustainable supplies because the
effect of all this will be rising prices
for consumers just when they're being
hit with other things too well you're
reassured by what alex sharma said about
the con about the continuity of supply
during this winter well i've seen what
he said and i've seen what the business
secretary has said uh over the last 24
hours i hope that's right uh because
continuity supply is essential as i said
um but this really must act as a spark
to
avoid situations like this where
suddenly we're very exposed when there's
an international price spike but what
would you do to make sure that that
doesn't happen because in a sense part
of this is a problem to do with an
unforeseen
event uh that's created a problem in in
the pipelines i mean how would you if
you were in government deal with that
well you'll see that the immediate
price break may be unforeseen but
the reliance on international markets is
foreseen and you can do something about
that by investing in your own storage
capacity by making sure you've got
alternatives to gas and we're going to
have to do this for net zero anyway so
some of this may be unforeseen but a lot
of it should have been foreseen and you
know we can't be surprised by net zero
like somebody being surprised by
christmas uh one year we've got
legislation that says we have to do this
and that means that government has to
have a plan to get there what does part
of labour's plan be to cease
uh the opening of new
uh fossil fuel streams for example the
cambo oil field in scotland or a new
coal field in cumbria would labor simply
say we're not doing that look
you know on individual plans they have
to be judged uh on their merits but the
overall direction of travel has to be
less reliance on fossil fuels because
there's no way to reach our net zero
targets which are shared across the
political parties unless we do that
but uh
you're sort of
if i may say so echoing what alex sharma
has said it's not really a decision we
can make now why can't anybody just say
you know what we don't want any more
coal we don't want any more oil we're
basically going to say no to these new
developments because i'm reluctant to
comment on one application i'll give you
two
at a time but certainly the direction of
travel must be that we decrease our
reliance on fossil fuels we increase our
use of renewables let me give you a
great example close to home trevor my
local hospital
new cross of wolverhampton has announced
that they will
run themselves completely with their own
solar farm saving 15 to 20 million
pounds on energy bills over the next 20
years all of that money will go back
into front line at nhs care so i think
there's a great example uh close to my
constituency in the town that i
represent which the government could
take a lot of inspiration from indeed
and uh my sky news colleagues have been
running story on that this this morning
but just let me make one last attempt
why can't labour simply say that there
has to be a compelling emergency case
for a gut the government to agree to
license any new fossil fuel exploitation
well the bar should be high for that uh
and there has to be a you know a very
convincing case given the overall arc of
where we've got to get to on 2030 so i
don't think these things should be uh
approved just on the nod in the way that
they would have been in the past because
that's not the future
the future is renewables and sustainable
energy and that's where we've got to get
to let's talk about um your your party
um
it's reported today that the mp for
canterbury rosie duffield has said she's
not going to the lab party conference
because she doesn't feel
that her safety is assured because of
comments and threats from
activists who object to what she has to
say essentially that
biological sex is a fact
the first duty of government is to
protect its people how can we believe
that labor can be government when it
can't even protect its own mps
well i'd be appalled if rosie thought
that she couldn't go to the labour party
conference oh she's not going yeah i've
i've seen the article every mp
should be safe uh at labour party
conference or at their own party
conference we had this a few years ago
you may remember with luciano
i was appalled then
and i think first of all
i want rosie to be able to go to
conference but
more broadly here i think there's an
important cultural point about how we
discuss things
difficult issues
have to be able to be discussed in a way
that doesn't result in if someone says
something that someone else disagrees
with
them being placed completely beyond the
pale and subject to
terrible online abuse or threats or
anything like that and we've got to find
a way
to work through issues where people can
say things where someone else might
disagree
uh some of these issues are not easy
without the consequence that you're
talking can we assume that anybody who
is associated with these kinds of
threats uh will not be welcomed
themselves at the labour party
conference if it can be demonstrated
that they either supported tweeted
shared in social media this kind of
abuse of a labour mp
yeah that should be the case and i think
it also underlines
the need for cultural change
uh you know we cannot have this kind of
factionalism uh we can't have this kind
of intolerance
and
you know i'm convinced of the need for
change in the labour party on many
fronts
okay but uh the internal culture is
certainly one of them and i would say
that kirsten believes in this very
strongly and he's been very clear about
this since he became leader